once all of the Prosthetics are in place
there are several minor touches needed
to finish off the look the parts of her
face not covered in latex need to be
touched up with blue makeup which is
carefully applied with special swaps to
achieve a delicate shading in these
areas more makeup is layered on with an
airbrush finally some fine detail is
provided all around using fine brushes
and stencils which are used to give a
textured look a final once over with the
airbrush some black shading around the
eyes and a set of false eyelashes
finishes off gillen's head and neck
Dylan is then given a final once over by
the team and then there's one last piece
to the puzzle as with the rest of
nebula's look her jet black eyes are
also achieved through practical means
according to makeup artist David White
Gillen was fitted with 22 millimeter
black contact lenses which cover her
entire eye to finish off her daily
makeup ordeal